dans ce point people on va aussi parler
de Stéphane Plaza pour rappel
l'animateur é visé par une enquête voilà
deux de ses compagnes ont porté plainte
contre lui de ses ex compagne depuis
l'animateur se fait plutôt discret
concernant cette affaire mais ses
proches n'hésitent pas à prendre la
parole après Karine Le Marchand c'est
l'humoriste et comédien jeanfanè qui
s'est exprimé c'était chez Jordan de
luxe sur C V Jordan de luxe bien sûr qui
est toujours là pour faire parler les
les people quelqu'un a vous l'avez fait
Jordan moi je fait plusieurs fois et je
pleure à chaque fois c'est ple à chaque
fois c'est comme le psy quoi en fait
c'est Jordan qui très trs non mais c'est
vrai il s'est tiré les vers du nez mais
avec
douceur moi je l'ai fait ouais ça va
passer bientô il m'a fait dire que des
Ding vraiment il est très très fort très
très fort il vous fait parler de truc
dont vous parlez nul par ailleurs est
persuadé que personne va vous regarder
ex
est l'émission la force de Jordan non
mais je que c'est vrai je te j que c'est
vrai c'est très fort ça fait plus que
faire plus matin
il va le passer devant
le alors là vous le voyez là il est très
boné il revient de vacances
là connais très bien il est très affecté
par tout ça parce que parce que ça c'est
ça c'est tellement soudain ça tombe d'un
coup vous l'avez eu quand la dernière
fois jeanfille la semaine dernière pour
mon anniversaire pour me faire plaisir
malgré le regard des autres malgré tout
ce qui se passe pour lui donc il est là
pour moi je suis là pour lui il a été là
dans des moments très dur de ma vie
Stéphane donc ça' montrer que je suis là
aussi pour lui et puis et puis c'est pas
le monstre qu'on essaie de vous vendre
parce que il est pas du tout ça donc ça
fait mal il a je fen ému là la fleur de
peau là la fleur de peau la fleur de
peau donc ma pouvez nous rappeler de de
quoi Stéphan Plazza est accusé ça il y a
une enquête internem6 qu' l'a
complètement pour l'instant enfin ils
disent que M6 aucun problème a deux
choses volet interne M6 en effet a a
blanchi entre guillemets Stéphan Plazza
en disant que en dehors de comportement
parfois un peu lour lourd de de blague
un peu potache il y avait rien de grave
il y avait rien qui constituait une un
motif de licenciement en revanche il y a
une enquête judiciaire qui est en cours
là l'enquête on est au stade préalable
après la plainte de deux excompagnes qui
l'accusent de violence conjugale il en
avait trois trois jeunes femmes qui
avaient parler à mediaap et deux d'entre
elles on ont décidé de porter plainte
alors il tourner des émissions pour M6
bien sûr ça se passe très bien avec M6
Gile oui et il faut préciser que
lui-même a porté plainte pour
harcellement au préalable en juin 2023
et que certains de ses proches ont à
leur tour porté plainte contre les
jeunes femmes qui accusent Stéphan
Plazza en disant qu'elles étaient
harceleux et cyber harcelé parce qu'elle
voulait absolument les faire témoigner
il par que Stéphan il sort plus enans se
cacher non il est il est pas en forme il
est très éprouvé il a été extrêmement
marqué c'est normal et il est replié sur
lui-même voilà il sort le moins il est
vraiment replilié sur lu
déguisé oui oui bah il a été marqué
aussi par toutes les manifestations
féministes qui ont eu lieu devant les
locaux de M6 et cetera et puis les
proches là Jean Fanen est assez
courageux parce qu'ils sont pas légion
en fait les proches de Stépan Plazza
défendre en dehors de Karine Le Marchand
qui l' bien sûr défendu tout en disant
qu' il a lequé mais les les gens le
défendre avec mesure là un discours
comme celui de jeanf janen en fait il a
été rare alors il y a Nicolas TAV
end a défendu regardez il s'est exprimé
Nicolas TAV son patron sujets de
violence conjugale nous sommes
extrêmement attentif que ce soit en
interne ou en externe dès qu'il y a eu
des informations de presse et j'entends
on n même pas attendu une journée le
soir même nous avons commandité une
enquête interne à l'intérieur de M6 avec
tous les gens qui travaillent avec
Stéphan plazard la même chose a été
faite chez media one ces deux enquêtes
n'ont donné aucun élément qui
justifierait une sanction contre Stéphan
Plaza ce qui concerne la partie privée
il nous appartient pas de nous
substituer ni à la police ni à la
justice pour prendre une décision nous
n'avons pas trouvé dans qu interne de
quoi le suspend de l'antenne et nous
attendons les décisions qui ont été
prises par la police et la justice en ce
qu' le concerne
oui non il a raison sur les faits c'est
vrai que d'autres chaînes avec les mêmes
enquêtes auraient choisi de le mettre de
côté et je trouve que c'est très fort
c'est un geste fort de la part d'M6 de
l'avoir maintenu à l'antenne et mine de
rien ça va avoir des conséquences sur sa
carrière à suivre il y a pas de stop à
l'antenne pour lui donc c'est c'est
c'est courageux c'est parfait il y a
rien à dire enfin tous les mots sont
pesés la justice va juger mais nous en
interne dit-il ils ont quand même
interviewé des dizaines de personnes ils
ont bossé ils ont travaillé ils n'ont
rien trouvé donc ils le maintiennent
confiance voilà voilà là ça en est où là
bah l'enquête se poursuit les gens vont
être auditionnés et ce que je voulais
ajouter sur Stéphan Plazza c'est vrai
que il a contre-attaqué sur le plan
judiciaire mais l'homme moi j'ai eu un
contact avec son entourage très proche
l'homme est extrêmement marqué c'est
normal mal parce qu'il est accusé mais
il est défait il faut pas croire que sa
contre-attaque veut dire que il s'en
fout que il est persuadé de gagner non
il est persuadé de gagner mais il est
extrêmement marqué il faut dire
extrêmement secoué par tout ça Florent P
le chanteur été élu deuxème personnalité
préféré des Français il a réagi à ce
titre et on a profité pour donner des
nouvelles de sa maladie allez-y continue
à parler tranquille là-bas problème il
dit prenez un café vous emmerdez pasy
regardez les enfants il y a 2 ans
Florent pan bouleversa la France entière
en annonçant une triste nouvelle on
vient de me diagnostiquer euh une tumeur
au poumon atteint d'un cancer du poumon
Florent pan a pu récemment remonter sur
scène et même sortir un nouvel album et
jusqu'à bout de
force recours de son é é preuve que le
chanteur qui devrait suivre
prochainement un examen de contrôle est
toujours dans le cœur des ses fans il
vient d'être classé deuxème personnalité
préférée des Français juste derrière
Jean-Jacques Goldman selon le J d
Florent PANI qui s'est dit ravi
d'apprendre la nouvelle s'est aussi
interrogé sur les raisons de sa position
dans le classement dans une interview
accordée au Journal du dimanche il s'est
également livré sans longue de bois sur
ses projets à venir et sur son cancer ce
n'est plus moi qui ai les commandes mais
la
maladie merci les 20 en direct merci Maë
d'être avec nous comment il va Florent
PANI alant pour l'instant il va bien il
explique en revanche dans cette
interview au JDD que le 15 janvier il a
de prochains enfin ces prochains examens
sont le 15 janvier et que selon les
résultats tout peut basculer dans en un
instant si les choses vont à peu près
bien il restera en Argentine en
Patagonie chez lui sinon il reviendra en
France pour se faire traiter à Paris
d'accord il va refaire ce Voice ou pas
oh pour l'instant c'est pas alors de
jours il va reprendre ses tournées ou
pas du tout en 2026 pour la tournée des
65 ans dans 3 dans 2 ans alors il a fait
un bon dans le classement des des
personnalités préférées des Français il
dit que lui c'est c'est c'est incroyable
qu' dit merci merci voilà concert c'est
ce qu'il a dit c'était assz drôle de
dire ça oui c'est toujours avec son
petit ton provocateur voilà mais en
revanche il dit lui qui est très épris
de liberté qui tient à ça farouchement
il dit que c'est la maladie qui le
contrôle et ça au quotidien évidemment
pour lui ça doit être très compliqué
alors il a dit j'aiétais honoré et fier
en l'apprenant mais je ne vais pas
sauter en l'air non plus la maladie a dû
peser dans la balance donc merci encore
cancer la maladie ne m'a pas empêché de
chanter bien au contraire ma voix est
même devenue plus claire car j'utilise
moi mes poumons que ma colonne d'air
plus bas dans l'estomac voilà il ajoute
je ne sais pas si c'est dû à ce que les
gens voient de ma maladie mais je
constate que les émotions sont beaucoup
plus forte maintenant dans le public
certains se lèvent dès que j'entre sur
scène d'autres tombent en larme étonnés
sûrement de me voir en train de chanter
ça fait drôle toutes ces émotions qui se
décuplent je n'avais jamais connu une
telle intensité je n'étais pas habitué
et il explique tous les 3 mois tout est
remis en question euh tous les deux mois
même puisque je dois aller faire le 15
janvier comme vous l'avez dit un nouveau
contrôle quand bien même je suis habitué
à aller mieux un simple contrôle peut
d'un coup rebattre les qu les cartes si
le 15 janvier les nouvelles sont pas
bonnes comme vous l'avez dit je reste en
Argentine jusqu'en avril sinon retour en
France pour réattaquer un traitement en
espérant que ça marche ce n'est plus moi
qui les commmande mais la maladie je me
suis juste mis une borne dans la tournée
des des des 65 ans ce sera en 2026 ça me
laisse un peu de temps voilà c'est
exactement ce que nous a expliqué Mael
donc c'est toujours jean-jaces Goldman
la personnalité préférée des Français